hello everyone and welcome back to
another video by simply learn in this
video we will see a comprehensive full
course on react.js react.js is an open
source JavaScript library used to build
user interfaces
Facebook created it and it has since
become a popular choice for front-end
development in this full course we will
cover all the basics of react.js from
components and states to routing and
apis we will also discuss the interview
questions and two interesting projects
on react.js that can help you land a
great job in the field of front-end
development let's dive in and look at
the agenda for this full course first
we'll see what is react.js after that
we'll see what is react.js components
moving ahead we'll see nesting
components higher order components and
then react crops after that we will see
react methods which is very important
after that we'll see react projects and
one of the project is Instagram clone
after that we'll see reactating new
features
moving ahead we'll see angular versus
react JS and by the end of this full
course you will learn react.js interview
questions and answers that are very
important for you to crack an interview
but before that if you want to become a
software developer consider the course
on full stack web development means tag
by simply learn and master those
necessary skills you can also consider a
postgraduate program by Caltech in full
stack web development check out the link
in the description box for more details
you can also call on the numbers that
are given below and know more about the
program so without further Ado let's get
into this full course in today's video
we'll be learning all about react shares
so let's jump in and see what's in store
for us so we'll be covering topics on
what is react why react features of
react react prerequisites and its
industry Trends let's go ahead and begin
with what is react react is a JavaScript
library used to build fast and
interactive user interfaces for both web
and mobile applications now one thing
that makes react extremely powerful is
the fact that it's open source any user
can access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
Jordan walkie an engineer at Facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
Works in real time consider a typical
web application say Instagram the entire
UI of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the ACT helps in
creation of dynamic web applications
where also provides performance
enhancements now there are several
performance enhancements like virtual
Dom and one-way data binding we'll learn
about these topics a little later in the
video react uses reusable components now
this helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other Frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to JavaScript using jsx
we can add HTML to the Javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of JavaScript and HTML now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a JavaScript notation H1
tags indicate HTML again the semicolon
indicates JavaScript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual Dom that is the
exact copy of the real Dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real Dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual Dom with the virtual Dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual Dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual Dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual Dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
Dom as discussed earlier virtual Dom
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
Instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one-way
data binding this means information
Flows In Only One Direction One Way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only JavaScript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
Facebook Instagram Pinterest Skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that Facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
applications dispatcher so that they can
receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal API of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer Community you can
practically debug react calls within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state weight and props are the essential
Concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a JavaScript class having some State
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the UI looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props are short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
confidence more Dynamic it is important
to Define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of HTML tag attributes now consider the
following code Snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming Concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
JavaScript and a familiarity with HTML
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the I.T industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the United States is a whopping 91 000
US Dollars the average salary for a
react developer in India is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by Google Trends
Riyadh has had a better growth scale
compared to other Frameworks like
angular and view statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react emotionally we have
Facebook Instagram Netflix Dropbox
WhatsApp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further Ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website say
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so I'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system I'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
I'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for Windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder I'm
creating it on my desktop while you can
create it in any of your drives let's
call it first react now open your
command prompt now you can type in the
path for the folder that you just
created so say CD
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm install
hyphen G create react app okay so this
command installs all the necessary
react.js modules now to check if the
version is correctly installed you can
type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create react app and you can
give a name to your application so I see
my app now this should take a couple of
minutes okay once you've successfully
created our application they say to
begin by typing the following commands
so let's do that save CD my app and npm
start this should typically start your
application and here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file open folder go
to your desktop or the drive that you've
saved your folder in first react
my app and I say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js or components
without delay let's begin and look at
what's in store for us so we'll be
touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order and pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the Facebook homepage the
entire UI can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the saline feature shares of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must Define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels the
component can also receive properties
from its parent components also you'll
get a better understanding of all of
these when we start working Hands-On so
don't worry so moving on let's look at
the different types of components first
we have the stateless functional
components and then we have the stateful
class components now functional
components are typical JavaScript
functions that return HTML now they can
be contained in a DOT JS or a DOT jsx
file coming to class components these
are regular ESX classes however it's
mandatory that they contain a render
method that in turn returns HTML they
can also be contained in dot JX or a DOT
jsx file okay okay then let's go ahead
and build our first react application
using components all right so I've
opened my text editor that is vs code to
build my application Also I suggest you
watch the react installation on Windows
video to help you get started the video
briefly explains how to install node and
how to start building your first react
application in my case I've opened a
folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder I have
app.js now app.js is the main component
that gets rendered to the term let me
show you that here in index.js you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the reactor so app.js
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
app.js is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this
and return nh1 tag that says hello
welcome to Sabri let me save it and if
you look at the browser you'll have
hello welcome to Centrelink now let's go
ahead and display another message say H1
this video is about components let me
save it and let me check the browser it
gives you an error so jsx uses a
conventional rule which states that all
HTML tags have to be enclosed within a
div tag so for example I say div and I
enclose it so let me save and check my
browser again here you go so multiple
HTML tags have to be enclosed within the
div tag moving on let's create a first
functional component to do that I'll
first create a folder in my source
folder say components within that I'll
create a file say functional component
dot JS all right so the first thing we
have to do is import react so I say
import react from yeah the general
Syntax for a functional component
involves the keyword function and say
functional component now now you say
return an H1 tag or I've already used H1
tags so I'll say paragraph
and this is a functional component
correct before explaining to you how
these components are exported and
imported let me show you the general
Syntax for a class component so I create
another file say class component dot JS
I again import react from react the
general notation is using the class
keyword followed by the name of the
class extending from the base class
react.component so going ahead I say
class class component extends react dot
component now the key feature of a class
component is the usage of a render
method so I say render within braces I
say return a paragraph tag saying this
is the class component
so moving on let's see how these
components can be nested into the main
component that is app.js components can
be nested into the main component using
Import and Export keywords so as the
name suggests export feature is used to
export a particular file or a module and
import is used to import a particular
file or a module into the current
existing module so we have two different
types of exports you have default export
and just export or named export so a
default export is used to export just
one object be it a function a class a
variable from the file and there can
only be one default export per file and
when you're importing it you can specify
the address and use the word import
before it so let me show you how it
works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here I say
export default and the name of the
function component that is functional
com so let me save this and going back
to my app.js I say import name of the
functional component that is functional
comp from and I pass the path this
components slash functional component
also let me get rid of these unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here I say functional comp let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well let's say export
default name of my component and in my
app.js I import it import class comp
From the Path and again I'll have to
Define it in my return method I save so
let me compile it and check my browser
it says this is the class component one
unique feature of default export is that
I can rename the file while I'm
importing it so for example I can rename
it as say FC and while I'm defining it
I'll have to make sure I use the same
naming conventions so I say FC again and
when I check it it says this is the
functional component there's literally
no difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
Etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so I'll
just copy paste this let me give it
another name say class comp 1 and then
message that I want to display is hey
I'm another class all right so when I'm
exporting it I don't want default so let
me take it off and say export here all
right in my app.js while importing it I
want to import both the classes so I'll
include them within curly braces here I
say class com comma class comp one and
then again I Define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey I'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that I can
choose to import the classes that I want
to now say for example I do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me comment this
now let's compile and see hey I'm
another class the second class got
imported while the first class I was
defined earlier is not imported here
alright so next up we have higher order
and pure confidence now I won't get into
the nitty gritties of it because they're
Advanced topics but to give you a brief
Insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click dot JS all right so here we define
a class I use this snippet rce here we
go we get the entire format using the
small snippet rce and here I'm going to
make use of a button now see I use the
tag button and I'll say clicked one time
every time the user clicks on the button
the value gets incremented so for this
I'm going to use a variable say count
and I'm going to use the concept of
States so let's go ahead and Define our
variable count and initialize it to zero
so for that I'm going to use another
snippet called R const and here this dot
State equals my variable count
initializing it to 0. so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
I say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equal is this dot update click Now
update click is going to be another
method that we have to Define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
Define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and I say this dot set state is
nothing but count this Dot state DOT
count plus one okay and here we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again I say import click
from components click and let's define
it here so let's check our browser every
time we click on the button the value
gets incremented all right so let's go
ahead and create another component say
counter.js wherein every time the user
hovers the mouse on the button the count
value increases so let's go ahead and do
that I say
counter dot JS I'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag I
Define a button and say incremented two
for now I say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button on Mouse
enter I'm gonna call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and Define the
increment count method I'm going to copy
the same code that I've mentioned in my
click.js so I say copy this all right so
one change is that I'll change the name
of the method and call it increment
count again let's define the count in
our render method so I say const count
equals this Dot and here I change X to
now let's go ahead and import it in our
app.js so I say import counter from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to 0 and every time I move
my cursor on the button it increments
mind you I'm not clicking I'm just
hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our SOC
let's call it higher order dot JS okay
so I say import react from yeah after
that I say const updated component
equals original component that's going
to be an arrow function again and within
curly braces I Define my class that is
class say new component extends react
dot component inside let's define a
render method that Returns the original
component with a modification that is I
want to type the user I want to append
the user before the actual message is
displayed all right so let's go ahead
and close the tag and return new
component and let's export this say
export default updated component now we
import higher order.js in our counter.js
and click.js and pass these components
as parameters so let's do that let's go
to counter.js and here I say import
updated component from dot slash higher
order component and here while exporting
I say updated com and pass this as my
parameter let's do the same to click.js
here I import data.com from higher order
component and here I pass this as a
parameter now here in a higher order
component we've defined a property name
and initialized it to the user so we'll
have to include this in our other
components that's counter and click so
let's do that and here right before
incremented 2 I say this dot props dot
name let me save it let me do the same
thing here and save this dot props dot
name so if you go back to our browser
here you can see it says the user
clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react Implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react
now pure component avoid unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the Dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the Dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component Now using
this example I'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a pure component.js file I
say pure form
dot JS so here I'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag I'll
display the text save and
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
I may call it regular component.js and
here I'm going to use the snippet rce
and the message that I want to display
is I'm the regular component so to draw
a comparison between the regular
component and the pure component let's
create a parent component for the two so
let me create one here I'll call it
parent component.js and this is again
going to be a regular class component
and here I display the message I am the
parent component to change the state of
the component we're going to make use of
a Constructor so let's use the snippet
or const and here let me create
name you can give anything and I say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did Mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead I'm going to make use of the
method and the same component did Mount
and here I say set interval the first
argument is going to be an arrow
function and the second will be the time
interval and I'm going to be setting it
to 3 seconds now within the arrow
function I'll make use of the set State
function to set the state of my property
however I do not change the name I keep
it simply on itself moving on let's
import your component and the regular
component into our parent component and
then pass name as a property so to do
that first import pure com from Pure
component and then I say import regular
com from regular com.js and here let's
say regular com name equals this dot
state DOT name and I say pure component
name equals this dot state DOT me now
let's include the property name in both
our regular and pure confidence so to do
that let's just save this Dot
prop.name and here I again say this dot
prop dot name and finally let's import
parent component into our app.js
component so here I say import parent
come from okay and here let me Define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have and the parent I am regular
components simply learn and I'm the pure
company we've got the result as expected
now to check if the pure component is
actually re-rendering or not let's
include simple console.log statements so
here I say CLG snippet and here I say
pure component render and in my regular
component I do the same thing I say
console.log regular component render now
let's do the same in our parent
component as well
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the pairing
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
component life cycle explains the stages
the component goes through the entire
life cycle of a component can be divided
into three parts we have mounting
uptation and unmounting so the first
thing that gets invoked in the life
cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once a component is
inserted into the Dom component did
Mount gets invoked coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component State
Should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the Dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and Cycles
in our previous video we learned about
react.js components in detail and now
moving ahead let's learn about another
striking feature of react.js called
props props short for properties allow
the user to pass arguments or data to
components a pairing component can pass
additional information to its children
using props properties help make
components more Dynamic props are passed
to competence in the ways similar to
that of HTML track attributes now we'll
look at this a little later in the video
props in a component are read only and
cannot be changed one thing to remember
is that props are sent by the parent to
the children components hence the
children components cannot meet any
changes to these props now that we've
learned about props in brief let's go
ahead and create our application using
props if you're new to this tutorial I
suggest you go to the react installation
and react competence video on our
channel so back in my code editor that
is vs code I've opened a folder called
react props and now I'm going to create
a component a class component and I'll
call it class props dot JS so let's
create the class component I give rce
the snippet and here I display a message
saying an H1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here I say import
class props
all right now we Define the class
component in our render method
[Music]
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
Hello Learners welcome to Simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here while
I'm defining my child component I say
name
I save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
I say I use a keyword this
dot crops dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner1
welcome to Simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner
3 so I again say class props name equals
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
Learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
Place X so I can hear Define another
property say place
[Music]
say please
similarly I can do it for the rest too
Place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello learner one
from this dot props dot place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello Lana one from
Place X Place Y and play Z we can also
display whatever we want between the
opening and closing tags when invoking a
component now this is facilitated using
props.children reserved keyword now let
me explain to you how it's done with an
example here let's split the self and
closing tag into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my H1
tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props top children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here I'll split it and add a button
tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go we get the output as expected
all right we saw the usage of props for
class components similarly we can use it
for functional components so let's go
ahead and create a functional component
let me call it
I say import react from react
and then I say function
function props
and here I return an H3 tag
say this is functional component
[Music]
and I'll return another H3 tag saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it export default
function props
[Music]
and import it in our app.js again import
function problem
[Music]
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call function prop
name
let me give learner 4.
and
place
Place say a
let me close it and back in our
functional component instead of learner
I save
props dot name
let me save it now if you look at our
browser it gives us an error it says
props is not defined so let's go back to
our code editor and pass props here
to our functional component also let me
Define hello frop start name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected
so let's begin and learn what exactly is
a state in react typically a state is an
object that stores the values of
properties belonging to a component now
these values can change over a period of
time either via user interactions or
network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality every time
the state changes react re-renders the
component to the browser the state is
initialized in the Constructor a state
can also store multiple properties a
method called set state is used to
update the value of the state object now
this function performs a shallow merge
on the new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while State on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once said by the parent they
cannot be changed State holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about State let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of State all right so in my
code editor that is vs code I've created
my application say State and here in my
source folder I have my app.js file now
here I'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that I'm not going to
be using Also I suggest you go through
the react installation on Windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react top component inside I
have a random method that returns an
HTML tag let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the HTML tags within the div
tag so I say div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app.css and so we save it and if you
look at the browser we have welcome now
let's beautify our code to do that let's
add some styling so here in my app.js
class component I say Styles equals
and I say font style and I set it to say
bold and I save color save teal and here
in my H1 tag I say style equals this dot
Styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first I create a
folder and I call it components and
inside this folder I create a class
component and I call it newcomp dot JS
and I use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to Simply learn once the user
clicks on the Subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the Bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state of object in a Constructor so
let's use the snippet R const to create
a Constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to Simply learn that's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name equals app and let's create
an H3 tag and within the tag I displayed
the message so I say this dot state DOT
message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component so
I'll get rid of export here and here I
say
import new com from components and
newcom and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to Simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
Styles so I'll just copy the same styles
that I've added here and I'll paste them
here and instead of bold I make it
italic and I change the color to say
purple and again in my H3 tag I Define
style and initialize it to the store
Styles so let me save it and now if you
look at the browser it's in italic and
it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the Bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that I want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here I
create a prop I say sub and I say
subscribe here and back in my render
method I say this dot state DOT sub so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the Bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here button on click I call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set State method now our state can be
updated in response to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
State method now this is the general
syntax used by the method we'll however
look at this further in the demo now the
set State method conventionally enqueues
all the updates made to the component
State and instructs react to re-render
the component and its children with the
updated State now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here I Define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions I suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here I say this dot
set State and inside I change my message
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update and myself up value changes to
subscribed let's save this and now if
you look at the browser when we click on
the Subscribe button the message changes
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a Bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and the thank you message
appears on the screen so for that I have
two images I have Bell a and Bell B so I
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder alright
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file here I say import Bell a
from Bell a DOT PNG and again I say
import Bell B from Bell B dot PNG all
right let me save it to display the
image on the screen we make use of the
image tag now this tag has two
attributes one is the source attribute
that specifies the URL and the other is
the alt attribute that specifies an
alternate text for the image so here in
my component I say I make use of a
paragraph tag that will help display the
image in the next line and then I use
the image tag now since my image changes
once it's clicked I have to define a
property and pass the event handler
click that will update the image so here
before specifying The Source let's go
back to our state and Define another
property that is image URL and let's set
it to Bell a since that is the image
that I want to display first let me save
it in here in my image tag I say Source
equals this dot state DOT image URL and
then we have the alt tag and I do not
want to display any message so I leave
it as it is now let's save it and if we
look at the browser we have a bell
displayed however now let's change the
dimensions of the bell I do not want
such a huge bell so back in my vs code I
Define style with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the image
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
Define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click and Define a method say
this dot image change and now we Define
this method here as the image change I
make use of a narrow function again and
again I use the set State method I
update the image so I say image URL is
now set to Bell B and the message is
updated to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally Let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution Let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
Subscribe button and now it says hit the
Bell icon and once I do that the image
updates and the message changes
hello this is Matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to cover react
with Redux so with our session today
we're going to go through is going to
cover why you'd want to use Redux when
you're building a react solution what
Redux is what are the core principles of
redox and what are those pillars that
drive what you're doing redox and then
finally what are the pros and cons of
Redux and after we've gone through their
PowerPoint presentation here what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
go through and actually do a demo of
actually using uh Redux so you can
actually see how this would all look so
why would you use Redux well the reason
why you'd want to use Redux is that
Redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object and redox
was introduced to help address some
problems that you're having with react
so the state of an object stores values
and properties that belong to components
that could potentially change over time
so the state could be modified by
actions in your network they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties and then with Redux
it actually takes in and actually will
create a you know take a a large
application that you could create with
app with a react and breaks it down to
several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-rounded with
which reduces the efficiency of your
application and so this is why Redux was
introduced
so you know what is redox so Redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
State container for your JavaScript
applications and it'll allow you to run
your applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key elements that I
like about Redux is that it's really
easy to test and so with Redux you're
able to manage the state of your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
JavaScript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words Redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
of the application can be described to
the store by the user and then it notify
is any modifications made to the state
of that application so let's jump into
the key principles of Redux and there's
three key areas I want to focus in so
the first one is that Redux provides a
single source of truth and that's our
source of Truth is being able to store
the state of your whole application in
an object Tree in a single store and
this makes it easier for you to debug
and inspect components of your
application it also enables you to be
able to persist your app state for
development and improve fastest
development Cycles the second principle
is a state is read only and that's why
you're able to describe more effectively
what's happening because it is read-only
and this ensures that no events like
Network callbacks would create and any
issues with the code and the
re-rendering of your application and
that object actions have become then
just plain objects and then finally
changes are made with pure functions and
so what do we mean by this so we can
actually take actions and transform the
state tree with a pure reduces and we'll
go into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of Truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of you taking to a previous
state the user can start with a single
reduce and as the app grows it can then
split off into a smaller reducers and
then finally the reduces just become
functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redox
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reduces
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
um and there are four key States there's
get state which turns the currency to
the store and when we actually run the
demo later on you'll be able to see that
we'll be able to open up our terminal
window and be able to get the state
store from our terminal window uh the
second state is dispatch and this is a
an action it's the only way to update
the application State and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe and these are our ways in
which you can actually change the
listener to the state so an action is a
plain object that represents an
intention to change the state so with
actions you have payloads of information
that send data back and forth to your
application store so you can send any
kind of data and they can go back and
forth and that actions must also have
then a type field that indicates the
type of action that has been performed
and finally with reduces reducers are
specify how the application State
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application State change they are
reducer is a function that accepts the
current state and an action and then
returns a new state with the action
performed and then finally you can use
combined reducers utility which can then
combine reducers in an app into a single
a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using Redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with Redux is that
Redux provides a single source of Truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
um this then leads to having a
predictable and strict outcome Redux is
more stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing Redux
code this makes it also then easier for
the initial render which allows you to
make your solution really optimized as
an experience and then finally
developers can track everything that's
going on inside the app in real time the
cons so one of the big cons is there's
no encapsulation so you're using Redux
to test out the code and the writing of
your code but the component cells can
access data and they there is potential
for security issues you do have to use
boilerplate code so this kind of takes
us back to the structured code format it
is
um strict and it's set up and it is very
intensive
so let's jump to the coding part and see
what's we are going to create so before
we jump let's open our terminal to
install some commands here I've already
created my react project you can also
create a react project it is very simple
just type a command npx npx
create
react app and then the folder name in my
case it's
and just enter it it will create a
portfolio app for you so I have already
created so I'm not gonna enter this so
let's cut this
after that let's begin with our
code
what you have to do is write a command
npm
react
install first install react
router
Dom
and then press enter it will install
react router Dom in your system
but before install this command you must
have installed npm in your system
so let's move forward
and enter
I have already installed this command
but just to tell you guys I'm entering
okay meanwhile it'll take couple of
seconds meanwhile I'm going to create a
folder inside this source
and let's name this folder
and
let's clear this terminal
now what we'll install is material UI
icons so for that the command is npm
install
add material
slash
icon
you'll press enter and it will take
couple of seconds again more install
this command
I have already installed these commands
in my system
first just to clear you guys I'm
installing them again
so
let's
start our development process
and say this
okay
now let's open this app.js inside this
I am going to import here
after that
I'm going to import the CSS file of this
I'm dot CSS
import
Dot
app
SC
issors
okay
now let's close this after that let's
create a function
app
save this
let's return
if
class name
app
after that let's close this
yeah
fine
the main part is to export this file
so we are going to write export default
let's save it
now let's again open the terminal
by just pressing Ctrl Place back type or
you can just go here and just type new
terminal
here we'll write in view start
if we start the react project for you
but let me write here
okay it's working fine so let me show
you that it's
create another
okay let's create here
and right
hello
let's save it
now let's open your
simply look
so it's working fine
let's just delete this part here
now we are going to start with our first
component which is header inside this
component
will create another part either
dot JS okay let's create another
four
folder
that this components folder yes create
another folder
let's stream its titled
here we'll add all our CSS on scss files
let's enter
inside this let's create a file
header Dot scss
so I am writing scss because I am using
this file syntax you can also use CSS
syntax also
so let's move forward with header.js
yet
okay
now let's write const
ant header
here
let me check the person
added function which will not return
[Music]
first step
with the Dead
and make it look most important part
again is to explore this file
don't export these files it will not run
so exporting file is very important
let's save it
and let's import our CSS file
which is
header Dot acss
or to addition
Styles inside the Styles it's header.css
yeah let's save it now
okay fine
let's open it
let's give the universal styling here
first
so by writing star it means it
implements on everything
so we'll give margin of zero
talk or let's first
wedding
hero
box sizing
for the Box
and save it instead
add pictures so
I'm giving every
let's save it
I will find
that's so open on this open your Android
device let's save it let's go to
index.js
here as we have installed reactor
so we'll write react
browser
route
[Music]
from as let's see
make use of router
router
and shorts
yeah find everything's so good
let's delete this
that's right router
[Music]
hey this roads all right
so
and so yeah
uh you
let seven
let's see can't fetched document button
let's see information okay
let's save it now it should be fine
foreign
[Music]
yeah
we'll add later let's fix this part also
fix ads
let's give it a
let's add the home component
[Music]
okay the element
let's save it now
let's fix this issue
um it's not closed
okay it's working fine now
yes now
everything look fine to me
foreign
[Music]
class logo
header
at the end of this tutorial you'll love
the output of this program so just be
with me
and you will see an awesome
portfolio for you guys that you can use
in your colleges or if you have a
professional the CV app will be a boom
for you guys
but
so we're creating the header part
so inside the header what should be the
positions that we are going to use here
so I'm going to add home about portfolio
Pages blogs contact these are the things
that in a basic portfolio are mandatory
so we are going to use that only
say in this H1 I'm going to write my
name
let's save it or let's try it here
let's save it
after that I'm going to create another
Dev
okay not
never
inside this new bar let's create an
ordered list
inside this
now let's create it there container or
let's
name it as closed
closed okay
inside this closed I'm going to use some
clothes
last name
has
slain
close
let's close this
C
I think fine okay
now let's okay let's just move on to
like the slip just close
inside the header
I'm gorgeous
inside this let's add
it
let's import our header
and save it
that's important manually here
foreign
let's save it
so let's
let's see now it's saying look
at the close we have an important this
let's import this
close
okay let's save it now
let's see everything looks fine
okay
it's taking a time to install
let's just move forward
after this inside this ordered list will
created
live component inside this will write
link
let's save it now again
let's import this one also
thought
link
and Report some reaction that we have
installed
we are routed done let's just save it
it's working fine now X
okay it's starting to look good
you have to add things here now
inside this link part
let's
link here
so
and insert that let's write
first one
[Music]
okay
it's fine
let's copy this component and leave this
three four five
hair will write
a home
out
about portfolio
portfolio
right
great vlogs
and then
contact page
let's just save it
it is successfully compiled so these are
the things that you have added
now the next step is
let's add the
to this
after this nearby
created Dev
inside that there's
let's name it uh change
let's add the
and the DVD where icon here
of many Our Kind
yeah inside this let's give it a class
name
menu
okay
that's right close this
okay let's save it
and exploring is done
yeah yeah it's already been added now
you can see the feature of react
this is we use the material UI icon
a new book outline and
automatically it's been called inside
this
let's now just run this and see this is
the icon that we needed okay fine
isn't it looking cool right now only
okay
let's work on the
header dot CSS
or scss
you can use whatever
position that you like now
the first thing you need to know
foreign
[Music]
just play let's make the displays Flex
only
because it should come and horizontally
so very nice and Center
you can change the position
that's right position
absolute
red index one
okay
let's now we did
the second fingers
okay
hello
inside this header logo will give you a
much enough
I guess
it's fine for that
let's see
okay
[Music]
about portfolio blog and contact here
so let's move forward with the code
[Music]
to
zero and Auto
we are making this profile nice
oneself so that's what we had used
so I have also used URL
project list
so we're going to display selects
and let's
set this really
calls for ni
Escape into Einstein
[Music]
so next we will give it a margin
after that it's looks good
yeah
no
okay
as I have used
let's make it does
check
so let's ride
next
so one thing I forgot to tell you that
if you're using like CSS here I'm using
scss if you're using CSS you can just
write after this UL tag on its list then
you can use like this
you will lay and inside that you can
write or you can just write Li and
inside that these commands we don't need
to write this inside the alert list only
okay
now let's add
stick stick position let me give you
action
give me a couple of minutes to add it
yeah
let's see
Define
let's select text declaration one
after that
text transformation
let's write down this form
case
color of this those
I don't need
let's run this
uh and what does it
look good
let's add it to partly
it's I don't
see here
after this
senior let's make this big
clicks
after that let's give it a margin of
right
of like
1.5 Filipinos
dot let's write
many children said this I guess yeah
so in CA says if this was the case
like this
we have created here like another
class of menu
in that we have written
you have to write all the
elements okay
we are using this as CSS so inside this
this is the syntax that they follow okay
let's write cursor
pointer
imagine right
one is enough
you'll also get the source code of this
in the description box
you can check it out
okay
it'll be helpful for you just follow me
throughout this video and in the end you
will see an amazing portfolio for you
guys okay
right close
cool
closed okay
close
portfolios are really amazing for like
freshers too
get a job because in these kind of
projects you learn so many new things
okay
so let's just save it
the point is yeah everything's look good
you have to give like more space here
if that did this then
let's write
okay
that seems look good
let's see
it's looks fine
let's add the horrible effects
will be created in this
we just get it
for you guys so
will be more
here is three ways
let me just add
everywhere
let me just copy the stack
okay
fine
you will see it be very bold
now let's save it it's working fine now
okay
inside this anchor tag only
that should
be effect by and
the given name power
at this let's give it the Border
button
three pixels would be fine solid in
color and the red is my color
let's save it and see what's the effect
okay as you can see it's looking
beautiful right
just be with me throughout this tutorial
and you will love the results okay
so
let's just make this clean
code should always look clean
okay
I said 15 it can be read properly you
can read it properly
so
after this close we are gonna go with
our code
I don't know why this cross is still
looking
let's do this close I have it in the
functioning but
let's see it's not fetching it right I
guess
no issues I'll do that
you guys okay let's see
what's the issue here
let's go to another file
close close okay
I think
good
Lord
[Music]
let's find out
this closes together
let's open the code
let's make this
like this
now let's save it
okay fine the crosses
clean and have fuel
so it will be like this
tablet mode
refine your things
let's go down right
let's make this
okay
to work on this part also
all right let's see where the dishes
coming
down
okay fine we have to still look or no
it's right here
again let's just save this file
[Music]
to that
I'm done let's write it
come on like constant
active
and make our app
[Music]
it's looking
it's showing I don't know but
State books function
calls
let's try the function now
const
ant show
in New
inside this let's give a better function
and insert this
step
always
this will do a strictly active this is
the meaning of this
save it and see the changes it's showing
actually it's not defined okay
so we want to find really
includes
one error is still coming okay fine
[Music]
we are not upstairs okay fine everything
will look good
let's see what's the issue here
constantly
when
oh my god
oh yeah now it's fine
[Music]
see because
finding errors and resolving them is
very important for a developer
increase your knowledge into the
specific language you are working on
so whenever you get any difficulties in
your code just take help from someone
Google it and you'll find the answer I'm
sure
okay let's find out
show me images
[Music]
all right let's use the show menu here
okay
inside this
close
said this
show
menu
okay fine
save it let's see the output
no let's inspected
find here
this is
okay the tools failed to the list load
Source man Cloud not load content okay
it's
right
let's make this a center
it's not in Center let's
go
okay
let me listen yeah
is fine
a margin is let's make it 1.2 here
in between them
it's three persons ordered okay
so let's change this part
right on click and then click
this
it will notice
[Music]
okay
let me save it it's gone by successfully
explicit between them
that's
working for you
let's have write a function
foreign
[Music]
everyone
you will lose
they can increase it
okay
at the
Justified content peace
between
let's play flicks
should come inside that function okay
please
on this one
Foundation
[Music]
web is
okay
done
what activities
at this point with some actions
so when I display clicks
in stain that text direction should be
column not true and there will be going
to mobile apps and all
should be
these are the little things that you
should
understand while implementing any
project or something
but it's very tricky also there's so
many things that you have to
cool
understand
[Music]
background color is very important
thing
said this that's right
okay
important also
please
now let's find
let's see this
yes we will
see you
[Music]
writing CSS is very lengthy process but
it's cool also we'll learn so many new
things by implementing
okay
excuse me
right
let's give them so much
so that let's
just ended
[Music]
foreign
Ty pixels
color
which is black but not like
look at the time yeah
folder let's save it
see
oh no it's
it's good
now
and you can see the mobile version of
this is
like this
isn't it good
everything
cool and responsive
coming back to our code
complete this one
return this is done
let's work on the changes here
[Music]
yeah
and this danger you will write
okay
that's right menu
display
line
I will like close down and close
okay
then display clock
to this one
[Music]
um
to the left wind
[Music]
View
of this let's
write another medium
okay inside this
to do all these changes just copy this
from here
put about this right here
[Music]
MP3 please
no
please so
one
and to copy this let's copy from here
let's just paste it inside this
everything will look cool
the next thing we are going to do is
take
create another one
Ginger inside this dot menu
inside this display on inline
block
in
right
you wanna save it and let's see the
header note
isn't it looking perfect
yes
going forward
having increased emerging from here
to 102 to 25 am
so now it will look like this
okay
now we'll work on this mean part for
that
let's cut this part
okay let's here add a new file called
[Music]
um
Dot scss
CSS you can write this CSS okay
and say this component part we're gonna
write
other file inside this let's mean
matters
okay
now we have created two files here so
let's open our main file
it's important
yeah
after that let's write
const basic
function of react
just the syntax only
so
it is let's return
the dev empty
let's write and get there okay it's not
this that's why it's
[Music]
yeah I got involved in exporting
default nothing
I will import one in the file this is
file of this
so we're gonna write styles
called a path
and the filing
save it
and look
the same
let's move forward
with our
app.js
in here we have two
declare that
port
mean from
compliments
okay yeah let's save it
now here I mean let's save it okay
combined successfully
now we'll do it
I'm going to add one
folder
pictures and I have created
inside this but let me just create one
a basic structure of that let me just
open my new your chest style here
and insert this means yes you have to
write some code
let's just
foreign
let me just do this and inside this
let's
add it inside this Source or like I said
the source
with this Source buttons will be fine
yeah
now I have added three pictures here
to write more pictures so let me just
copy some images
yeah give me a couple of minutes
coming back let's move this
inside this view
let's create another class
[Music]
and dinner
and Signal let's close this
move
class name
and
let's just close this one
another
last name
text which will be used in this
we need to try to be done
not those
[Music]
okay let's create another paragraph done
and
somewhere a little more aesthetic
designer okay let's save it
and see the output
is it looking good right
okay
Okay so
everything is lost because
make it inside this header also
so
let's see
if we are going through this Source we
are missing here
dot yes one
[Music]
okay
inside this header
group
to this video
let's just move here inside the head and
then just
out
okay
guys are done let's just focus on the
thing which is
creating will resolve it in a while away
so this is done
and it's just
create another Dev inside this
class name
to other icons
so let's make this class name as icons
only
will be helpful for us only too right
all the CSS properties for this
so I'm gonna add the CSS
directly
so it will save your time
we'll find the code
in the description so
and I'm going to show the code here also
so you won't
in this copy it
okay
that's right
Facebook
the class new Facebook also
[Music]
and let's okay it's not that
just copy this room now
and
[Music]
so
I think
okay we haven't called it yet it's
speaking
material requirements so
yeah let's call them
Instagram Facebook Facebook
right
that's not called up here so that's why
here
and now I'm still LinkedIn which is left
so save it and you'll find all the logos
here isn't it looking amazing right
okay
I'm sure you're loving it now
here we'll add them
picture
is that
I'm going to add first let's just
complete this part only
uh let's add in here for like
hire me
whenever anyone will click on that hire
me button the CV will automatically gets
loaded
okay let's just work on that part
let's create another class
[Music]
and if you will guys find any
difficulties you can just comment it
down I'll be happy to help in it be well
guys
want in this front-end development
I am going to help you guys
hope
just talking in there
h i r e e
that'll be fun
okay let's just close this rapid now
and this
let's create another class
name
buttons
so let's just add one more here
that's right
uh
let's write connect on with me that's
right
that
Tycoon we are going to write in that
folder so it's right
see
you it's fine
okay let's save it
inside this buttons I'm going to clean
each links
Vietnam
buttons it's fine
it's just deleted
from that
in this book
save it see the output row fine
I'm loving it
let's just turn forward
okay
I see you have
inside this let's after the
let's add a little bit diff
iculty
inside this class name will write mean
s
you are the image source
that's right
you
foreign
[Music]
so we're going to import a new
message
spelling of that folder was a s s
DDS
in the file name that we are let's
spread the properly press
it's right
through file
[Music]
dot jpv let's save it
oh it's coming really big
it's a different picture here
trade
you aren't working you would work
and
see let's save it
that's coming behind
and make it here also magnets
save it everything was looking perfect
now
and make it here like here it's it'll be
fine okay let's I have already added the
CSS part
you can just see here
okay
it was saying that I have showed you one
here
just a few new things already I'll tell
you if I have added anything
very well look good
to
yeah
okay
nothing will look good on you
that the buttons right
images
[Music]
there's some line is coming in the down
that's why I'm doing this
a little up
put it from there to
qualified
yeah this is looking good
but the picture is here so it's sticking
this part only so it's kind of colors
too
to put interviews in this part
okay
this is looking good
clean and good
let's move forward
okay
let's move forward and create a part
here in this complement
file called
section
Js okay
inside this section.js
and let's just now going to be creating
particle that
let me just write
okay
dot dot Js
let's save it
okay we have written so we have to work
on these two files also but let's just
start from here
it's I've also added these files in one
order
so let me show you guys first here
I've added these files like contacts
comes in the second okay let's just cut
it from here
so as the header will come main page
section
and then the contact
like this
this layer right save it cut it you
don't need this
everyone is done the in file is also
done in the section and contact
let's start with the section part
okay
this
by just writing import
yet
okay
let's
write styles
section Dot
sections section dot is CSS
yeah
cool
now we are going to import for one more
chair which is
let's write on two
assets
and inside that it should be let's see
the picture here
let's add
this picture yeah
Egypt
I have to call this inside this function
that we're going to write because let's
write
it
conversed
shoe
inside this section we are going to
create a function
set this return
there
is export basic structure is
the basic structure is ready okay
let's just write something
seeds
okay
let's just add these
command here so that we can see
that's right
last name
let's write the classroom section really
like the sections
let's create another
nice name
sections
antenna
so bad
if
class name
sections section
image okay
yeah fine
now we're going to add the image with
the source
what will the source
two
hold this image
empty and let's close this
okay
let me just see here
this thing
okay
yeah
okay for you
you are working on this part let's see
okay
yes
let's write the index function now
that's
[Music]
just work on this part first
then also we can switch to contact page
and we'll complete this part then we'll
do that okay
for now let's work on this section part
only
after this section part let's now add
okay fine
let's create a div
as name
section
the content that
we are going to see
after that H1
and this I'm going to write my name
a little description about me okay
and experience
working development
after that
this will be
uh
let's write
some stuff like
script development
you're like listening
yeah
you can write anything of your choice
about yourself
I'm gonna write Java
python
now
I'm also into project management and it
said
but it's like
no
yes
okay let's just save it moving forward
everything looks fine for this
save it
with one warning let's see the issue
state is defined but never used let's
find out
now that we have completed the rest of
the part let's complete the last part
which is contact.js part in this
let's create the
board
react
from react
now
let's import the CSS file here
let's try
command dot styles
inside the Style part it's my CSS which
I have created just now
after that
let's not add anything else it's fine
for now okay let's create the
options
that Arrow function
now create
return
this
export
fault
contact
yeah everything's look now
that's cool yeah
now let's start
with the class name
contact let's save contact
you'll love the result in the end I'm
sure
link
to just to link the app
I am going to add the empty file
path
so it will get Linked In The Arrow
pack
class name
huh
Pedro
let's just close this
okay
I mean things looks fine okay yeah
that's the reason here
yeah
still we have to
import this link
from Ria crocodone
link from
via router down let's save it
now
okay yeah we have to import the Arrow
background
material UI
I wrote back
from
at
icons let's save it okay fine
everything's look good now
okay yeah just create another div
class name input
where the user will input their detail
or if anyone wants to send a message or
something
inputs
after that I'm going to create one H1 it
will be the head of
contact
me
okay
after that I am going to create
input types it is input
which is text
and the placeholder would will come
inside that with name
let's close this
and let's copy this few times copy
paste okay
the second thing that a user wants is
email
and the third thing that I want is the
message that they want to send or
something
and last name is
message because this box gonna be the
big one no the name one is like the row
type email one is also the same but the
message box should be big that's why I
have written here the class name
so I'll go and edit it inside my
CSS file
inside this let's create a button
of send
okay let's save it
now I'm going to open my contact CSS
file
to add some CSS
on that
let's give a width of like
100 percent
height of 100 percent
then the background color should be
White
mine would be fine
after that
[Music]
the B
text decoration we don't need let's go
and write none
dot input that we just taken
inputs right
and
so let's write here
width of 60 percent
eight of 80
percent
margin of 0 and Auto
and then
simply should be
X
Flex Direction because of calling
and Alignment item should be Center
and then just 5 content
Center yeah
now what we will
just work on the bedroom Direct
one inside this let's give the color
I have noted down the color let's write
it RGB
[Music]
comma 76
76.
okay
let's click on the input type now
let's give it a width
it comes Center
pattern
should be 20 pixels
outline
and
and the Border should be also
let's work on the last few steps of this
application
bottom
then
after that let's open the button part
the ding will give of 10 pixels and
40 pixels
background color or this background only
first always pointer
chin
top uh
border of one pixel solid
we have to declare the color also so
we're gonna give it a color blue
yeah
okay
now color is defined
no it's not defined so let's get pink
but let's
give it a little darker
yeah this is fine
text
let's
forward
add media
Max height
Max width we'll start with
pixels
inputs
inside this input and we're gonna take
width of
and then the input size would be
wedding
and then 15 pixels
let's save it
and okay fine fine inside the app.jss
Let's see we have declared the contact
page here
let's save everything now it's
successfully compiled
so this is the final step of our
application
so these are the header part mean part
that we have created here
so you can see the hover effect
isn't it looking nice no you can just
write a mail
email ID message and just send it
isn't it looking amazing
you can always improvise the projects we
have created
so you can also improvise this so with
this we have reached the end of this
video
I'm gonna write Instagram
and this is how at the end of this
tutorial you will see your Instagram
clone okay
so
let's jump to the coding part open your
Visual Studio code
now let's create a react project
for that open your terminal
new terminal
you can also open your terminal by just
pressing Ctrl plus back type okay
here I am going to write a command to
create react project is
npx
V8
react app now the folder name I'm going
to create as insta
Instagram clone
okay
it will take a couple of minutes to
install all the files in libraries
so let's wait a minute
as you can see it's installing react
react Dom and react Scripts
so let's create a couple of minutes more
I'm sure at the end of this tutorial you
will love the output as you are going to
create a straight simple and fascinating
Instagram clue
okay let's wait a minute more
okay
now
okay it's taking a minute more it's fine
we'll wait a minute more with this
after that
we're going to open half folder here
I'm going to create a react project
like in this Instagram clone I'm also
going to create the login page inside
the login page I'm also going to create
the sign in page when the user enters
their view ID and password
they will be redirected to the home page
now
let's see how our application is looking
first we are going to go inside the
folder that we have created so I'm gonna
write
Instagram
clone
now we are inside the Instagram clone
let's open our folder
where all the files are
so inside the C
users SLP
here is my folder let's open it
and see
now we'll open the terminal by just
clicking on control backtech
here I'm going to write
npm start to see whether our project is
working fine or not
so
let's wait and see the magic of react
react is a beautiful library of
JavaScript
okay you'll love the output in the end
I'm sure
let's see
so here it is the beautiful logo of
react
now coming back to visual studio code
let's install the material UI component
of react for that I am going to write a
command
let me just search here
foreign
this one
but let's copy this command from here
it's copied coming back to our code
let's paste it and enter
I want to install all the files
okay fine let's sing
here the root folder
okay let's just see in this Json file
icons have been installed or not
okay
there are so many packages here the
react is all dependencies react even to
your Dom your script
and
it's not installed let me just
again
find them okay
let's write npm
install
just a minute
yeah right
4.11.2 okay
so it will install automatically
here I'm going to open this app.js file
it as you can see just let's run this
file now npm start
let's say it's working fine or not
okay it's working completely fine
now coming back to our code
let's delete this logo we don't need
that
and let's delete this header
here we'll write H1
inside this H1 I'm going to write hello
from Simply learn
let's save it let's see what's the
output
isn't it looking cool
at the end you will see in complete
full-fled Instagram clone it'll be
awesome let's see Instagram
okay fine
let's delete this one we need
okay
let's move forward
and
delete this one
because we don't need it
also I'm going to delete this file also
let's delete this image
okay
here
now I'm going to create components as
react is a component based Library here
I'm going to create different components
for this project
let's create a folder called compo
Nance
inside this components folder I'm going
to create a folder called
login
page
inside this login page I'm going to do
files
as login
Dot login page dot Js
and
inside this login page only
let's create another file called login
page.css
now
instead let's just save it for now
open your login page to a CSS not TS
port
or we can also write
import react
comma
here I am going to write
component
yeah
from react yes
I'm going to create a class of login
page
inside this login with extends I'm going
to use
state in this
component
let's create a Constructor here
okay
say this let's write a prop
and set this let's write a keyword super
props
after this let's
this dot state
to get the state inside this okay
now render
this function
to return
div
let's give it
hello
world
let's save it
okay we need to export
export
to export each file you need to write
default
and then the file name
like login page let's close this one
let's save it
now coming back to app.js
here I'm going to write
login
page
and as you can see
it automatically
imported the
login page from components login
okay
let's just save this one and see the
output
so
it's working fine
come back to our code
let's
okay it's fine
let's import react
come after this
I'm going to
import
we're also going to use the credit
system here okay
so for that
let's go back to our code
it's
it's a great help so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to make this screen into
three parts like three
to the left side three to the right side
and six to the middle
okay as you all know
so the screen is of 12
so I am going to use this 12 okay
let's
open our login
create a div now I am going to show you
how to create
a screen
firstly I'm going to take one div
inside this div I am going to write
create
container
inside this grid container
to add one grid
item
of exercise
okay
do not come under this it's
okay fine
yeah
here I am going to write some demo data
hello
to just let you know how the grid system
works
now
I'm going to create one another let's
let's
write the proper
hello
here I'm going to write from
and here I'm going to write
simply
let's save it's showing an error
okay
let's find out the error
everything is looking fine to me
let's see what's the issue here
okay
the grid is not defined okay it's fine
fine
got to add the grid
okay here I have added one command for
the grid yarn add material UI code
as this was not working
so I'm again going to add the material
UI
so let's see that working fine now or
not
wait a couple of minutes to see
if it work that will be great
so let's just see the Instagram
login page for now let's just log out
from here
okay
let's just open this
Instagram yeah this is how
I'm going to create the login page
so I have these pictures this one this
one and this one
so inside this
sign up page I'm also going to
create this signup page and this login
page okay
so it'll be very great if you'll
understand the process
the react is a very beautiful language I
love react
so if you love react
subscribe to our Channel
post
amazing videos on a daily basis
so this is almost done
now
I'm going to start this project
will not work within previous let's
let us
see is it working or not
okay fine it's working
so as you can see it's saying okay let
me just delete this part
index.css let's delete this save it
coming back to our page
images okay
let's just save it
now
as you can see this is taking what this
piece which is
from here to here
okay
and this from is taking
space from here to here this Big Grid
and this simple learn is taking this
much space only three
so we have distributed this 3 6 3 inside
this 6 we are going to work
so coming back to the code
now we are going to create the
login page
so let's
hear
inside login P dot GSS
JS let's add here yeah
inside this let's cut it and let's
create a def class
okay
inside this let's create another div
with this div I'm going to add one image
let's write the source of that image
it's
insta
website against
image
okay this is not necessary
okay that's why it's not fetching you
have to import the image in the top
so let's write import
instead
just remember whatever you are hitting
inside this
you have to write it here also so
this is inside the source
inside
the
folder dot okay first it is inside the
Instagram clone then Source then inside
that images
now inside that
I have added one image folder here I
have added some images they'll be
important and useful in this tutorial
okay
I'll give the link in this description
box for this project you can just get it
from there okay you'll get all the code
don't worry just see how everything
works okay
so here I'm going to write the code of
that image it was 9 3
6 4 6
okay it was seven five f
two six
dot is
SG
now let's save it and see the output
okay
it's saying we have packed come by with
one warning it's nothing image element
must have an old okay it's fine we can
do it in the CSS part
you can see the output here
isn't it amazing we can just adjust
everything don't worry about that
but it's working
let's
you can add here like alter this image
hide width you can give
okay
now let's move forward
and add the width
let's give its width as
okay we can give the width has
and pixels let's write okay
450 would be fine
yeah let's space here
okay yeah
it's completely working fine
I will give the padding and all
it's fine
but for now it's looking beautiful yeah
let's open that page where that
yeah it's already down let's again login
we face this login page okay yeah it's
up so let's make it
up only okay
yeah it's looking very beautiful
coming back to the code
after this let's create another div
let's insert this let's read
okay we have to make the Box
so let's
okay let's you can also add the image
here
yeah
now we need what let me just see once
okay we need one container inside the
window we need that image
of Instagram okay fine it's easy
no big issues
okay
let's
right here again this
copy okay it's copy
and now let's paste it
so the name
so the name of this is not insta image
it's in
install logo
so what we are giving not right now
let's not go it's fine if we can
okay we have to include this
inside here
okay
let's
copy this import
paste it here
and install logo
from the images
seven five b 206a
yeah it's fine
let's add the name
insta
logo
dot PNG let's save it coming back to the
code it's showing error can't resolve it
okay
let's Okay okay fine
I understood
so
it's not it's done it's
the
let's save it
now is it the same issue
it's the same issue
let's search for installment.png
okay fine
now coming back to our code
we'll see
install logo dot PNG
okay fine everything
it's logo and star
in just a minute
it's not this one
it's the
okay let me just find
local things as here
let me just
there
okay
let's write here
save it
yeah
it is working but the image quality is
very bad
moving ahead let's find another logo
is there any low Bond size here
we can use this logo insta
let's try this one logo insta here
let's save it
let's see that yeah this is also working
fine
okay
go with this one only
back to the code
it's fine we don't need this
but we can test this one
now let's give this first as a class
so we can also give the CSS properties
okay
so for that I'm going to give it a name
as login page
and Main
let's just save it
and inside this okay let's just delete
this one
no no
to write
login
page
in
go inside this
I'm going to write display
then it should be
Flex
save it
coming back to the code let's see
okay it's fine
again I'm going to write login
being
we need for log only
so that's coming
the next line let's give it the width
I've already given it a word so
we added from there
let's
in different pages
let's not mix it here
okay
let's see it's so coming very big
unfitted I guess
but no issues we're gonna make it work
yeah
login page
over the Cs is not working okay
I forgot to add the CSS in this login
we also have two
add this CSS so I'm gonna import
Dot
login
page Dot
CSS let's save it now and see the magic
of CSS with
react
okay
looks good
back to the code
it's looking very slow
no issues evaluate a couple of seconds
because
okay it's not working
look it's
let's move forward
so
we are going to add this logo here
what is coming
here
you want this
inside this so let's
login
page
right
opponent
say this
is going to write
okay everything is
let's give it a height of 380 as it is
as Instagram login page
[Music]
it's 350 pixel
the border of that box which is one
pixel
solid
[Music]
let's give the exact color that
Instagram have
okay let's just save it now
see everything is attached
okay
let's just see
Instagram one is looking very big here
let's reduce this size
let's see the warnings here
it's still compiling okay let's kill
this terminal
delete this one
inside this creating new terminal
let's write and then start and see
whether it is working
fine or not
let's just delete this
okay
it's coming inside that the only
let's see whether it is fetching the
login page
mean is correct
we have to add the
files here to fetch it okay
let's just copy this one
let's add it inside here
first let's read
chat component
here
will be paste
class name as login
which
case they were
login
right
opponent
let's just save it
here also
for this image let's give it the class
name
login
page
logo
save it now and see whether it is
working fine
okay let's hope it's working fine yeah
we have created one box and this is what
our Instagram logo
up
let's open our
terminal
so
it's fine
we don't need this one
one for the main
or one for the script container
I'm going to add one
two
[Music]
three
we have created one div here
yeah it's fine
now it's looking
up
like here earlier it was looking down
now let's remove this
till now
we have
gotten the idea
for y we have taken this
okay let's make
it systematic
yeah let's save it
now
as you can see
in our app
and in Instagram
there is this one
margin on the top
so let's open our CSS
that I'm going to write margin
25 pixels let's save it
yeah
our app is also looking like the
Instagram login page
right
and then it started looking cool
right okay
let's make it as here as it is showing
you inside there
yeah you have to give betting to this
Instagram
like
you have to create this also
so let's
give it some space here
let's
let's give it margin top to whatever
thing
so it should align C
uh inside the mean also
I'm going to give margin
55 pixels okay
now in this right
I'm going to give it a border which is
fine margin is fine
margin is what fruit top we need
so
let's save it
this text line is
Center so our Instagram will
be inside this container which is Center
isn't it looking very similar to The
Original Part
now let's move forward
with the next step inside this container
I am going to create
these phone number and all okay
let's work on this container open your
login.jss
this file
after this
let's create
a
div
inside this let's create another div
so
yeah
there are two divs
there's some space in between these and
this so
it's fine
I'm going
to
open this
let's write
class of login
page
h i g i n
written the wrong spelling
now let's write input text
inside the we have to use the placehold
you have to use that
placeholder
like you also have to write these things
now
okay
let's write
similar input for password also
input type
okay
it's not text
type which is
I am asking
type
and the type of this is password
see
yeah
it's for username password we can just
make it
looks similar to the original one
with the help of
what CSS right
let's create a button
let's write sine
okay
let's just save it
you'll see one sign button yeah like
this
coming back to the code
let's write
let's
let's okay here we are
let's make it with CSS you have to give
the class name
last name we are going to give
let's leave it simple only login page
text
type this let's copy it from here
and let's paste it here
so button I'm going to add another class
as login
button
let's just save it and see the magic
it's not showing let's see what's the
foreign
first we are going to add the
whole login text
and I'm going to write these three
page width
let's write 258
which is the exact same
height
which is 36 pixel same again
I've inspected these things so I'm
pretty sure of that
login
button
inside this let's give it the width
of
70 only
because the button should be
small
now let's see
yeah
okay we need to do some
changes here also well it's coming
outside of this container let's see
is we have added here inside the
container
okay
here I have done few changes in the dev
now
as you can see
it's coming inside the container now
you're gonna give some space
so for that
let's give them some margin within your
piece dot CSS
and here
I'm going to give it a margin
of 5 pixels
okay
also I'm going to give it the Border
because color is very dark there
I'm gonna change that solid
and
DB DB DPS file yeah
and this is looking good
and we have to create one more
which is
login
page
sign in
inside this let's give it a margin from
Top
as
25 pixels let's save it
and see the changes yeah
so
now the color of this is looking exactly
like them
this one now coming back to the button
part
let's just
add the
there
will be creative field it here
huh
as you can see here
get someone coming inside this because
we have
open this one in the
let's close this
let's first add the placeholder or let's
work on the button bar okay let's
just add the placeholder which is phone
number username or email
so inside this text now
we have to add this placeholder
to this I am going to add one
placeholder
it is going to tell us what's
comes inside this
number email
or
usually
okay
and inside here let's create another
placeholder
select this let's write password
save it
okay it's called
the email is coming
username
r
save it yeah
it's looking amazing
right
now coming back to the CSS file
let's give it a background
text yeah
after the water we are going to give it
a background color which is a little mix
of white
so I'm gonna write hash
f a f a f a let's save it
now it's a little bit
dark white okay
same as
this original one
yeah
moving forward
let's now
coming back to the code
let's
cut this one
let's write this
okay
we're going to give
heading left too
10 pixel
yeah this is coming fine
let's just
add one more which is
border radius here
5 pixel is fine yeah
no
okay let's give
this button some height
after the hide you're going to give it
border radius for 5 pixels
after that font weight
let's give the font rate bold
and then we need order for this
which is one pixels solid
and the color would be
okay let's see the color here
the original one sky blue okay
bye
the sky blue color is zero three nine
five F six let's just save it
okay
it's coming great
but let's just
mixer
because we need background color of this
as blue so
three nine five six yeah it's a little
dark
okay
and the color of the button should be
White
so
you can just
let's see yeah it's coming beautifully
right
whenever we hide the ID password Here
okay
forward
let's
work on
gifts
to minimize this
let's
add here body
okay we need to fetch this with
add Dot
background
color
and the background color of this would
be
a little
you just see the original one
okay it's fine
okay
that's why it only so we write FFA
yeah this one is great
okay
coming back to the right one
the center we're going to give it
back around
color which is white save it
now let's give this button a margin
margin from Top
because we need to add some space here
so we are going to give it the margin of
5 pixels yeah this is the line now
now
let's see whether it is looking fine or
not
so
it's looking completely fine
so now we're going to split the screen
as power and all
so coming back to app.js
now we'll work on this part
this or
log in with Facebook in this everything
coming back to code
here
I am going to create one div
ided this we can see the output
okay
let's create one Dev
inside the step I'm going to create one
div
modif
let me set here we're going to write r
okay
looking cool I guess
save it okay with all is coming but we
need to add some CSS here
so we can just
make some space here so let's
write this class name as
login
please
divider
let's save it
okay
let's give this one also a class name
as
login
or
here also we need to get some
class name as
login
divider
okay
now
we should also get this one last name
because
the E2 I did this also in the CSS
I'm going to give it as
if
let's save it yeah
let's open our CSS file
let me just add the CSS here now
here I have added some CSS properties
you can see it
okay
so let's just save it and see
this is the r
now
let's work on this one
though
login with Facebook forget password okay
let's move
okay
so I have added one class of log in
Facebook here I am adding the image
where this is the keyword FP which is
can fetch in the import
login with Facebook and then another div
of class name login forget
password
and
here
hitting this FB
from the image folder
let's just save it and see this is how
it is looking we need to shrink the size
of this image
let's see the original one first okay
it's coming very small but in our case
it's coming very big so what we can do
is we can go to our CSS file and reduce
the size of this
login Facebook
so I have added here
margin top is let's add 10.
and see the changes
nothing is here
so let's wait
let's not
ice the
here we can also
add the margin
right
so why can't we give the width here
it's right width
15 pixels
and let's see
yeah it's coming beautifully
right
now
coming to this 4-bit password
you can make this as a hyperlink also
okay
but let's just give some styling to this
log and feel let's a little less
okay let's just do it now
so
let's give it margin right
let's save it
for the image got lost
okay we just have to give
the exact
number which is
5 pixel now
what it is saying it's saying this okay
okay
this can't be fixed from here
it's again
okay we have given
now it will be fine
yeah
yes it's looking good
now
will work on this
sign in and sign up button
let's just
go to our
project
there we are going to add
because we need to come out of that main
container
okay
so here I'm going to create one another
container
let's give it a class name of
login
page
okay
sign
up
options
okay
inside this let's create another div
class name
login
page
sign in
close this now here we are going to
write
don't have any account sign up
copied
and here we're going to paste that
right
now
we are going to create another Dev
let's
let's give it a class name as
login
page
sign up
it is
the trade
around
sign
foreign let's just save this one and see
our page
yeah it's coming
up
what we can do is
let's see what's the mistake here
it's coming inside the container but
it's not fitting inside this
okay
this one is fine
okay the sign up for 10 sign in is fine
this one is looking good
add it here yeah
now it's working fine
yeah
now what we can do is
you have to give this a little bedding
so it comes under this
so coming back to
line up
the top is
e
yeah
don't have any account sign up
your account sign up
and then how we need to add
get a app
let's first form this now
get the app
let's minimize this this one also
let's refresh and it's coming perfectly
fine
as I'm not going to add these data we
can do that
but I'm not going to do that
so
let's add some images like this one
here
for that
let's write here open
clone look at the app after that
I'm going to
create one another div
at this I'm going to add these images
okay
images source
store
close this one
to that again
image
source
Play Store
let's save it
okay
we have to
add the images imported
second
yeah let's import this app store and
Play Store images
let's copy this one
called copy
paste
that I'm going to write
App Store
and here I'm going to write Play Store
and the image name is
app
and this one is play
let's just save it
and see
okay
it's going very big we need to give it
the width also
let's
code
Errol here we are going to give it some
width
let's give this one
pixels
yeah and let's copy this
yeah let's paste it and
yeah you can see the output
you have to make some padding and all
okay let's coming back to our code
let's give this one
sign up page all its
it's good another
option
okay
let's let this one only
let's fix this
let's skip this images
class name
as the login page
this one
engines
yeah
now let's copy this
and
after this image
I'm going to paste this one
let's rename this option as
and here also
you are going to Let's see we can see
it's there's changes
get 10
it's coming really
get the app yes
with this only so let's do something for
that
let's add here as
load
section
okay
let's
this one inside this stuff
is this one
it's it's still in the background
okay
let's just do one thing here
now it's looking fine yeah
so we need to give some padding here
let's give it some petting
Here Also let's just copy this property
only
paste it
save
now it's coming beautifully
there is some Gap here so let's
add this
watching motion
okay
I did this t w i n g but
okay this is a mistake
I thought it's not fetching the right
margin
it's not fetching the right margin
let's just
open the CSS
right
top save it
it's
margin is fine
okay we need to give some margin in
between the
okay
so let's just see
in download section
say the download section we need to give
maximum padding
from here we have given some padding
buds
and things were fine so let's right here
the login page option is also 40.
but it's not getting the space I want
so let's open this one again
it's a login option
and log into it
with this one
Martin
top
fetching this one
okay it's fine it's not that big deal
so
a login pages
done
so this is our login page
and this one
is Instagram login page
so
whose login page is looking more
beautiful guys
I understand
so let's move on to the home page
new Visual Studio code
here inside this Source component
I'm going to create one folder
inside this component folder
and folder
iMat
of home
which
inside this homepage component I am
going to create two files
let's name each of them as
on dot Js
and the other one is
Dot
CSS
yeah
let's save it
yes
let things look fine now let's open
let's delete
this also
we have fetched the login video
everything looks good
let's create
the
Port reaction
react but I am importing component
okay
let's import the CSS file of this
code
um dot CSS
okay
let's create a class of home
now we'll see whether it is working or
Not by giving it up
let's
props again
super keyword
tool fetch props
and this date will show us the
state of the program okay
now the main thing
friend of
here you are calling the last we need to
declare the render function
so
let's give it
low
from simpler
let's close this
again
need to export
for all
file name
let's save it and let's import it this
page
inside the app.js
now
as you can see
we have already reported login page
now I'm going to import
home page
now oh it's right
import home from
components
each
okay
let's save it
see is this in the brow ser
showing some errors
foreign
okay let's open this
source
component
create okay
this folder is created let's
cut this one
paste it here
okay let's cut it now
now it should be working fine
let's cut this files
seven
now it will be fine
what is showing
hello from simple learn right
code
back to the Instagram page let's see
so this is how the Instagram page is
looking
what I am going to do is
create one nav bar in the top
s navbar component which will
so we'll get plenty of space to add the
stories and the vector and this
what we can do is
we can just
hit one
component of nav pi
then we will follow the same let's code
inside this component folder
let's create
another folder
Dot
now in this
JS and
CSS file
yeah
another bar dot Js
as well now
CSS okay
now coming back to
page
coming back to
let's
copy this
let's copy this
and paste it inside number.js
editor
take nav bar
or GSS component
render let's delete this file here
export
okay never
let's save it it's showing an error
let's see what's it is
what should
okay everything
okay
it's right here as
my bar
so we can just
get what it is showing little
speed and save this
inside this I'm going to declare the
net bar
we faced
okay
okay let's say this div
okay let's
let's start now
let's
okay let's save it now
okay it's fine let's save it
let's create one more
components only
let's
main component
will go right back
yeah
inside this main content will create
again two files
10th
cheers
and mean content dot CSS yes
okay
now
again we'll go to home copy this text
and then back to main content
let's delete this right
main content
let's delete this also from here
in 10th
also this
here
content
fine
let's save it now
it's done
let's see
let's go to home it
here call
this mean content
let's save it and in app.js
let's comment it down for a while
browser which
here
's my body
oh
save it now let's see the
pepper
and mean content okay
so
as you can see you can fetch these files
okay
let's develop easily component like a
button mean component
now inside this
let's
bar
and let's
create one div
ided
as
r
but
okay let's
close it
now here
I am going to use
create
from Material UI
yeah let's save it
okay
let's see
a one component has been created
let's create now
create here let's hit this
let's give it a name
I'll create
container
inside this container I'm going to call
for
it's
victim one is excess
let's do
let's just copy this from here
well let's just save it
okay
thank you
because
let's see
that see
there is this issue that was coming
integrated
so I checked and the grid was not
properly installed in our system
now I have a game called what this
command npm install
slash four
this F is denoted as forcefully
and again it is installing material UI
core
it will take a couple of minutes install
all the properties of grid
mullets
analyze them
this will be resolved while
so we have to import the skills also
and these icons we can get it from the
material UI
can be helped here to Mentor the stories
and one company for the pictures
and one component for this one
let's go back to our code
still installing
shoes
will always be
let's just
get
now
and that is never only
let's import
logo
that we needed
all the packages
go
for that
okay
let's add here
inside the images folder there is a
picture called logo
and stop
EMG
okay fine let's
let's
use this part
okay just cut this
okay let's first just see no whether it
is working or not
thank you
okay let's open this one
see you
stitch in the editor
sign
of it
so we have
finally compiled this program
successfully the main problem was that
was declaring it
should not come out
this order file it's a module so we have
to import it like this so
output of this program is like this
this is the component which is nav
program
this is the main code
okay things
which will come under this our story
part
the neighbor
declared the Instagram logo
okay inside this
let's add it
over here and the image we have already
imported the
image on the top
that's right
install logo
let's just close this one
save it
showing the big Instagram logo we don't
need that we can
change it in The Styling bar
and
let's
give it a worth
let's try
pixels
save it
okay
so I can add the styling
bar
logo
okay
now let's see it's coming very beautiful
let's just delete this part
icle space
yeah
this looks good
right
and back to this
let's
start
input
text
search option of that
placeholder is what you know guys
let me
it
is complete that box you
will now let's save it and see the
implement
this search box yes
yes okay we can do the credit union
stupid
let's create the
grid here
come
inside
three three six seven eight
minutes
let's go
Style
set this I'm going to add
display
which should be
reflex
okay
it's this
and let's import some
which
one fine
other ways
let's give it a word for 25 pixels
save it
copy this one
paste
okay another line
yeah let's
go back
emotions
so when it's on one is
Siege
other one was
go to find button
the last and final one little right
as you can see
it comes the grid of the screen is 12.
so we have used 11. now I am going to
create a new grid here
let's give it size of
U1
and that would be empty
okay
now let's import the images on the top
first of all
again
that
is
name of that is
okay let's paste it
yeah
let's write frame
also the name of the images
let's save it
okay
Can't Touch This free aggressivity
let's see
no let's check
it's coming beautifully
yeah
I have to clear Instagram icons we can
also write these names but I'll take
much space so
as you have noticed there is one
file
portion also
which is round and inside that
there is a picture
so what we can do this
let's go to a code
let's see
okay
here
let's give
class name
bar
search
it's
everything looks fine to me
let's create this
screen
now
this is the time we can
add the
logo
Beats
each this one okay
we can do this we can import
Avatar
UI core say this is
but which is this one
right head
yeah
no
you have to declare this inside this
so what we can do is
star source of the image
DP you have to import this image
the
let's first
image
Style
and inside the style I'm going to
give it
Max height
Max High
let's try it
sign us
25 pixels
then Max
with
let's give it does
now it's looking good
so it is again
25 pixels
close this one
save it
as it is showing letters because we have
been imported the
image
so let's write
let's write the name of the image
save this one
still showing two errors let's make them
yes
what's together
up let's just create one more terminal
let's kill this one okay
set the network only I understood
but let's just run this one
that's right
this problem
so what we can do is
actually okay this
this weekend removed now only
with the prominent problem is without
can do
will not found
chair
which is
what
we're looking
condition
let's save this
so whenever we find any error just copy
that and paste that inside the
Chrome
on stack of flow you'll find plenty of
answers of that
so our main issue is with the avatar
maybe it's installed or what
words
at this point
okay
it's read some documentary there
now
again it's the same issue
with that
it's working fine
yeah
it's just coming
in that properties no issues that
let's give
it a little more sense to it
and let's see now
here on this one is looking
fine okay
yeah
coming back to the code
no let's style them properly
okay
image I'm going to give it the class
name
so let's keep
it because
limit
what we don't need
this
image
okay
yeah
let's just copy this
and paste it here
and here let's save it now and see the
module okay
yeah it's coming beautifully now right
everything is lying
and you can see the nav bar very
beautifully aligned
now this is not looking very good this
main content let's move that first
okay
let's remove this one
now you see this is how the nav bar is
looking
isn't it beautiful
right
forward coming back to visual studio
code
everything is fine I have added the CSS
properties you can see
okay
well
I'll upload all the code in the
description box you can just copy that
from here
okay let's
move ahead
now let's close this number
is
main content we will work on
first thing first what we are going to
do is
I'm going to import grid here
so uh
let's remove this from
and let's
add the proper location of the grid
fine
let's write here
grid
container
inside the script container
I'm going to add two grids
is
size them as
to
six foot
okay let's
close this one
let's sing right here
great
item
six
the main thing what we're going to do is
inside this
okay
space
let's create here
okay
let's give
it one
It Here Also let's complete the
structure okay
now
where we can just
add the size here
is fine everything is look good now
we'll start working on this this
so let's
let's add here
on dev
and type this
let's
that's it
let's first here you can
let's create two folders or components
status bar
okay
and then status bar again we are going
to
create
two files Js
and CS
status bar
CSS yeah
right now
we are going to create one another
component
which is main pitch
again in this main page folder
folder
still it is
okay okay fine yeah
okay let's create
in page
into the this one page
again
and
base dot Js
15 last email
.css
okay
that's the mean
page
and the status page it will come up
because data should come
okay
click let's just
capitalize this
okay let's save it
everything's look fine now
let's import these files inside this
first we'll import the
status bar
um
State this bar
did this one yeah
then we are going to import this
page
from
you can
yeah let's save it
now
you can see here
that because you haven't declare
anything inside this
is switching it
now let's just
part
let's give you the class name
as me
mean
10th
container
in this save it
back to status
going to import
okay let me discard this part
copied from
from the place
cut this one
if
it's
this
okay we just have to import the
react
components
from
you react
yeah
let's just save it
Israel
it is important this is status bar
so it is bar dot CSS
seven
data Square
function
say also
default
the status
let's just
open diff
status bar
okay
wait from here and set this
let's paste it
stood some modifications here
okay
let's save it
here also
and page
and
when it comes to exporting the file
set the tab
yeah
now we'll see the output
so
this is our nav bar this is the status
bar this is the space that we are giving
to this
status bar and this is the space which
is the main page
coming back to the code
status
status bar
where all the stories will come okay
right
so let's create another div
status
okay let's close this
hurricane
so after that it conversated
let's save it
dog
eat this
but
status
it is source
status image will declare the image
yep
costume
please
status
hi
yeah
okay yeah
let's just copy this few times
let's just
imagine
let's
board
status image
image from
images
while
okay it was
yeah
isn't it looking amazing yeah we have to
align it but you can see the status bar
let's add more
status let's let's copy this
and add two three more here
yes save it now let's see
yeah
this is looking really very good okay
you have to align it into the center
okay
yeah
let's
come back to the code
let's see
now what you have to do is you have to
make this container that status part
into the center of this mean page
you can do it right
okay fine
I'm going to add the status or the
pictures here you have to add the
container into the center on your own if
you need any help you can just comment
it down I'll help you out okay but now
you have to do some things
so that you can learn about this
technology mode
now we'll work on this main page okay
now
let's create a folder here in the
components
as post where we'll add the pictures
inside this again I am going to create
two files
JS and the CSS for The Styling yeah
os.css okay fine
now what we'll do is
let's copy this
and paste it inside this yeah
and
here
we are going to give the right path
post
let's skip the lastly post and then
we are exporting here is post yeah
save it
now
let's encode this into the main page
okay
let's show you an adder let's see
what's the
in there
okay
let me put we will imported it
the reason it's showing this error
post from
post
and then post
let's save it now
let's say this
okay this is
[Music]
maybe let's cut it from here yeah
paste it here now save it let's see this
also
everything looks fine now yeah
now
how we can check this is working or not
is
you have to add here
hello
save it
this would be fine yeah it will be fine
now we can add the pictures here
okay
this instrument yeah
it start working on this company let's
see this hello
inside this first div let's create a
classy
and let's
almost
and things
yeah
now
let's leave it as
you have to remove it after that but
let's just now
the better Clarity of this program
to
read this
okay
again I'm creating another div
in like this you have to create
okay
let's
do it
yeah
okay
let's delete this
next thing
let's create a tree like this
yeah
okay
it's fine
one component we have to create there
okay
inside this first header
what I'm going to do is
let's see the Instagram component
okay
so there is one image
and the username okay
one
let's
okay
inside this there let's create a class
system
post
there
okay
after that
inside the another container
let's write here of that because we need
to add the
logo
okay so let's give it a class name
of post
images
and let's write the source which is
d
that I will
send
okay
yeah
now one thing more we have to add is
that you have to add the username as we
discussed
you have to add the username so I'm
gonna write post
username
and then inside this
okay it's not necessarily but let's
write the username
okay
in this component
I'm going to write the
image okay
let's see that it feels like this
names and all okay fine let's move
forward
it's imported
let's save it
you can just
tilled it after a while it's not an
issue
now
let's move to the image component let's
and take this div and I'm going to
create the image
source of the image would be
post image
let's add the width here
width is
that's right 600
pixels
let's just save it
you have to add the English for now but
it's fine
okay
now let's remove the
image
Dot
post
image
from
images
these photos I'm using this picture so
many times
okay
let's save it now it should be
completely fine
yeah
so with this
we have created
are simple
for beginners
Instagram clone
so with this we have reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
it
let me just show you in the last how the
login page was looking
okay
let's just
and let's show this
save it
you will find the code in the
description box don't worry if you have
any questions you can just ping me down
and I will also add this part in the
code
in those sections part
we'll see the new feature that are
introduced in react 18.
the first one is concurrent features
then we have transitions
and after that the mean is suspense on
the server
moving ahead now we'll see the
improvements that are done in react 18.
automatic batching
better rendering
and then performance
so some things are changed like before
we used to write react Dom dot render
wait let me explain it for you
after we installed react 18 go to the
index.js file
there change the react Dom dot render
now we'll write react Dom dot create
root to create a root and then render
our app using root let's discuss about
reactating
so react was released in March 2022 and
you can install it with the help of npm
and yarn
let's move ahead and see what's new in
react 18.
so there are features like automatic
batching transitions suspense on the
server and concurrent react
now we'll start with the automatic
batching
so in automatic batching All State
modifications made using event handlers
are grouped together using react
buildings batching functionalities so it
prevents the files from going through a
pointless rendering procedure react 18
also features a modified version of
batching called react 18 automatic
batching that group All State
modifications made by create route
together so automatic batching is
nothing but to do all the micro tasks
together at the end of the task to save
time let me show you an example of
automatic batching earlier the program
used to render in each step but now with
automatic rendering this will only
render at the end of the task
so as you can see in this program this
set is fetching false set error null set
form status successful okay so earlier
first render will be performed in this
part set is fetching the second render
is performing when it is calling set
error and the third render is performing
when it is calling set form status okay
but now it will just read satisfetching
set error and in the last it will render
at only one time okay so this was
automatic batching
let's move ahead on transition
so a transition is a New Concept in rear
to description between
urgent and non-urgent updates in Urgent
updates it will reflect direct
interactions like typing clicking
pressing Etc the transition updates the
transition of the UI from one view to
another
so let me give you an example if you are
doing a task and another urgent task
comes in that has a higher priority so
react will stop that task and work on
the higher priority task
and then start the task again
so the transition is done like this okay
if you are doing one task and some other
urgent task comes up it will stop the
earlier task and start on the higher
probability task
now let's move ahead with this suspense
on the server
before react 18 was introduced if one
component of an app is slow it slows
down the entire app yes but with react
18 if one component is slow it will not
slow down the entire app now suspense
allow you to instruct react to send HTML
for other components such as loading
spinner before sending HTML from the
placeholder So This Server renderer will
then insert its HTML into the same
stream once the slow component is
prepared and has fetched its data react
suspense is a feature that enables
developer to monitor the rendering
element while the process is still in
process
it then displays its fallback
functionality
this functionality can be used in
conjunction with the transition API with
the most recent react version it even
pauses the rendering schedule to lessen
the effect of loading by preventing the
content from being changed
okay the render sequence is quite
helpful since it provides a calm loading
State while the user is still dealing
with a network conflict okay this is a
very good functionality that has
introduced with us since react 18 comes
with a sequence it allows us to
designate fallbacks for UI element that
are yet to be seen on the screen
therefore using the sequence tag we
could wrap a single slow component And
Delay the component loading also you can
configure a fallback to show a loading
animation so this is how we used to
write the code
but now with the help of sequence we are
using the code like this
okay let's move ahead and talk about
concurrency in react
now react can interrupt pause restart or
quit a render in react 18 with
concurrent rendering this enables react
to react rapidly to user inputs while
engaging in the time consuming rendering
operations we will also talk about the
examples of concurrent rendering later
but let me first tell you react 18
introduced the foundation of concurrent
rendering and new features such as
sequence stream servering streaming
server rendering and transition are
powered by concurrent rendering as a
react developer you concentrate on how
you want the user experience to be
delivered and react take care of the
technical details now let me give you an
example
concurrent react can remove UI elements
from the screen and add them later while
restoring the previous date
react should be able to restore the
previous screen in the same state it was
before for instance when a user tabs
away from one screen and comes back to
it we intend to provide a new component
name off screen in a future Miner that
follows this pattern off screen can also
be used to create new user interface
element in the background so that they
are ready before the user reveals them
now we'll talk about a new hooks so the
new hooks are introduced in react 18 let
me talk about them
so the first is use ID
use transition use deferred value
using external store
and use insertion effect
you can use all these hooks now we'll
talk about the strict mode
now the strict mode is more stricter
okay when using react 18 strict mode
components will be mounted unmounted and
then remounted with a previous state
by remounting trees using the same
component State before unmounting react
will be able to instantly mount a
previous screen in the future
thanks to the reusable State now we'll
see the changes done on the client
server and library site
okay
let's start
change is done on react 18.
one is client side
server side
and the library site now we'll talk
about the client-side changes in client
side render is now being created as
create root as you can see in this image
we are first using
if you open the index.js file in your
react you'll see this file okay in here
you will see we were using react Dom dot
render but now it's like root dot render
okay like create root here importing the
create route now the cons root equals to
create root now we can use the root
because we also gave the constant root
equals to create root
now moving ahead on the second one which
is unmounted component at node is now
become root dot unmount okay so before
we are using this function but now it's
like root dot unmount then we'll call in
the element
now now we'll talk about
react.dom.hydrate which is now converted
into hydrate dot root
call hydrate in react 17 and Below to
attach react to its extinct HTML that
was already rendered by react in a
server environment
using this react 18 will warn that your
app will behave as it fitsu running on
react 17.
now we'll talk about the server side
changes
on server side render to pipe stream is
now on the Node environment and render
to readable stream is on the edge
environment and render to string is now
deprecated
now we'll talk about library site
changes
there are new features like use ID using
external store use insertion effect now
let's say you're using an Instagram
application
every time you refresh new content is
loaded onto your screen
you can like a picture add new ones
search your profiles and do much more
although it provides a seamless user
experience there's a lot that goes in
the back end as well
so every application typically consists
of the front end the back end and the
database
together they form the full stack
so what exactly is front-end development
then now front-end development is the
part of web development that develops
and creates the website's front-end
elements or features
now a front-end developer in a sense is
responsible for everything that you see
it could be text alignment navigation
colors Etc
now the main objectives of front-end
development is responsiveness and
performance
so now that you know what front-end
development is let's look at the skills
that will help you land a job
first up is the foundation
so first things first to become a
front-end developer you need to start
with HTML move on to CSS and JavaScript
now these are the actual fundamental
languages for front-end development HTML
is used to structure our web pages CSS
is used to make them beautiful and
JavaScript is used to make the program
run and add interactivity
however knowing just these will not help
you you will have to learn the second
important skill that is Frameworks
now there are several front-end
Frameworks that make development way
easy now to name a few of the most
important ones we have react this
angular
View jQuery and Amber
now I'm sure you must have heard of
these Frameworks react is a UI
development Library written in
JavaScript
all the react is just the library and
not a framework its usage is rampant
nowadays react goes beyond simple UI and
has many extensions like flux and react
native for complete application
architecture support
talking about angular again this is an
open script JavaScript framework based
on typescript
so as a framework anchor offers
advantages and it also provides a
standard structure for developers in a
team to work with you know it allows
users to create huge applications that
are easy to manage
talking about view it is also an open
source JavaScript framework and is again
used to build user interfaces for single
page applications
now I'm sure you must have heard of
jQuery which is again a trendy
JavaScript framework and application
development platform
it is linear it is fast loading and
comes with features that make life of a
JavaScript application developer more
accessible
it is used more and more to be the
foundation and the primary driving force
of web development today
and lastly we have Ember which is again
an open source JavaScript client-side
framework it comes with built-in
environment with fast rebuilds Auto
reload and the test Runner
so these are some of the Frameworks that
you're expected to be proficient at now
the third skill that is crucial is
Version Control System
now we use Version Control Systems to
track our code history and work more
collaboratively with others that's why
you will find it in every job
description now there are multiple
Version Control Systems available in the
market today there's git their sub
version
Etc so just focus and git which is the
most popular one and don't worry about
other Version Control Systems knowing
these Version Control Systems will
definitely add more credibility to your
resume
the fourth skill that is crucial is the
CSS preprocessor now to give you an
insight into why we need preprocessors
CSS is an old language and it has its
own limitations if you write CSS for
medium or large size applications your
code starts looking messy so every time
you want to change something you end up
breaking something else
instead you can make use of a CSS
preprocessor now a preprocessor is a
program or a tool that lets you generate
CSS from a different language that is
better and more compatible than CSS
so instead of using plain CSS you can
use another language that looks pretty
similar with CSS we give our code to a
CSS preprocessor that converts it into
plain CSS which every browser
understands that's the purpose of CSS
preprocessors there are many of these
available today there's SAS less and
stylus to name a few
and lastly the most important skill
required is testing and debugging now a
very important aspect of web development
is to make sure that the end result is
error free
of bugs and seamless experience for the
user
therefore the ability to test and debug
a website is another essential skill
that a front-end developer needs to have
there are various methodologies that can
enable front-end developer to make sure
that the websites or the product not
only looks good but also functions
smoothly so although these are the top
five skills that a front-end developer
must possess they must also have good
communication and interpersonal skills a
good understanding of apis and how the
app needs to behave is crucial to make a
good developer
so you must be wondering how can simply
learn help you with this
well you could get started by acquiring
a simply learned certificate all you
need to do is head to our simply learned
page and type in full stack developer
you'll get a brief overview of the
course and what it offers if it suits
your requirements you can go ahead and
enroll for it having this course
certification will definitely boost your
resume
hey guys I'm sure you all have heard
about phrases like web development full
stack development front-end and back-end
development
but if you are not sure about what
exactly they mean or how they're
different then don't worry you're in the
right place
this video on front end versus back-end
development will help you differentiate
the two
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
now let's Jump Right In and look at
what's in store for us
so first we look at what exactly web
development is
then we look at the different types of
web development
going ahead we look at what front-end
development is and understand what
exactly back-end development is
and lastly we'll be comparing the two on
the basis of languages libraries and
Frameworks skills job roles and salary
so now let's begin by understanding what
web development is
web development is the process of
creating a website on the internet
it refers to the non-design aspects of a
website such as creating features and
functionality using programming markup
and scripting languages
developers concentrate on the technical
aspects of web development such as
architecture programming application
integration and graphics
now let's look at the different types of
web development
now web development could include the
front end and the back end
now together
they form something called as full stack
development now I'm sure you're
wondering what they actually mean so
let's go ahead and understand them
let's begin by understanding what
front-end development is
now front-end development is a part of
the website that codes and creates
front-end elements of a website which
are features that are directly viewable
and accessible by the client
essentially a front-end developer is in
charge of everything you see be it
styling Graphics text alignment
navigation colors Etc and the attempts
and he attempts to improve the user
experience to make it as seamless as
possible
now these front-end developers also
contribute to the overall design and
aesthetic along with debugging
responsiveness and performance are the
two main objectives of front-end
development
then what exactly is back-end
you guessed it right now web development
that occurs at the back end of programs
is accurately termed as back-end
development
now this back-end development covers
server-side web application logic and
integration and activities like writing
apis creating libraries and working with
system components as opposed to
front-end development which focuses on
customer facing services and programs
now back in developers create code that
allows database and an application to
communicate with each other
essentially a back-end developer handles
what you don't see we are in charge of
the back end of the website which
includes servers databases and
applications
so now that you have a brief
understanding of what front-end
development is and back-end development
is let's go ahead and compare the two
so we'll be comparing the two
based on five different features that is
languages libraries and Frameworks
skills
job roles and salaries
now let's begin with languages
now front-end development typically
includes coding using languages like
HTML CSS and JavaScript now as you all
know HTML is a markup language that is
standardized system for tagging text
files to achieve font color graphics and
hyperlinks now CSS is used to format the
layout of these web pages
and JavaScript is used to create
interactive elements on the web page
when it comes to backend the languages
include python C hash Java Perl PHP Ruby
and some JavaScript now Java in
particular was built from ground up to
run on the server side so Java is
extremely useful python is also one of
the most popularly used languages and
c-sharp language is the preferred
architecture for backend programming in
Windows environments
now talking about libraries and
Frameworks front-end libraries and
Frameworks include react.js angular view
jQuery and bootstrap while talking about
back-end Frameworks we have expressed JS
node spring Django flask JSF
asp.net and dotnet MVC
now front-end and back-end developers
work very closely so it's helpful to
have a foundational understanding of
front-end developer Technologies like
HTML and CSS as well
moving on to skills now front-end
developers are in charge of bringing
visual elements to a website as well as
interactive elements such as navigation
buttons and anything else that improves
overall usability
HTML JavaScript and CSS are frequently
used to ensure that a site's visual site
operates well so it's crucial to know
these languages and a good understanding
of JavaScript Frameworks and libraries
is also essential
and other General skills include a good
grasp of front-end programming languages
the ability to create a responsive
design the knowledge of testing and
debugging and an understanding of
front-end development tools like
automation content management Version
Control Systems
talking about the skills required for
back-end development
now back-end developers deal with
back-end languages and Frameworks like
Java Ruby and rails Etc
now back-end developers deal with
languages like Java Ruby on Rails Etc to
make web pages and applications operate
now it's vital to know commonly used
back-end languages and Frameworks like
Django node.js Express JS and so on
other important skills include database
management framework utilization
programming knowledge of accessibility
and security compliance and
understanding requirements in ensuring
data consistency and integrity
now moving ahead let's look at some of
the job roles for front-end and back-end
development
talking about front end we have the
front-end developer the CSS or HTML
developer we have front-end web designer
we have front-end SEO expert full stack
developer and a UI developer
talking about backend this back-end
developer Java developer full stack
developer devops engineer
software engineer and an iOS Developer
and lastly let's look at the salaries
offered to these front-end and back-end
Developers
in India the average salary of a
front-end developer is around 6 lakh
rupees per annum
while a back-end developer earns about 7
lakh rupees per annum in the US a
front-end developer earns around 100 000
US dollars per annum while a back-end
developer earns about 121 000 US dollars
per annum so what's in it for you we'll
first get familiar with both the
programming languages by going through a
quick introduction then we will compare
reactant angular focusing on their
performance
after that we will discuss the learning
curve for learning both of these
Frameworks we'll also get to know about
the adoption of these Frameworks and
their application in the field of web
development after that we'll compare the
community support available for each
framework
then we will dive into the industry
Trends and job prospects and in the end
I'm going to tell you which technology
to choose but I will give you enough
food for thought for you to choose the
technology that suits you and your
project best
so let me first give you an introduction
to react
now react is a JavaScript library for UI
development it is managed by Facebook
and has an open source community of
Developers
the framework was introduced in May
2013. it is currently one of the most
popular front-end libraries for web
development
moving on to angular
angular is an open source JavaScript
framework for web development and mobile
development
it is typescript based and is managed by
Google's angular team and the angular
developer community
launched in September 2016 Angela also
known as angular 2.0 is a complete
rewrite of angularjs which was
introduced in 2010. it competes directly
with react front-end Library
moving on let's go ahead and compare the
performance
now reacts performance is greatly
improved with the introduction of the
virtual Dom and is generally better than
that of angular
react uses the concept of virtual Dom
that puts less load on the browser react
was released with the USP of being
faster than other Frameworks available
furthermore since the data binding
process is unidirectional bindings are
not assigned Watchers as in the case of
angular
when it comes to angular it performs
worse especially in complex and dynamic
applications
the performance of angular apps is
negatively affected by bi-directional
data binding angular uses traditional
Dom that updates the whole web page even
if a single element is changed
however the most recent update of
angular has greatly improved its
performance and it does not lose to
react anymore
so moving ahead let me give you a brief
insight into the learning curve
react is a library and not a framework
it is quite simple to understand if
you're familiar with JavaScript
however it takes time to learn how to
set up a project properly so you need to
learn the Redux Library which is used in
more than half of react applications for
State Management react depends on other
libraries to add functionality constant
framework updates also require
additional effort from the developer
next to understand
some complicated features are embedded
into the framework core which means that
the developer cannot avoid learning and
using them
angular itself is a huge Library so
initial learning effort is worth it
since you probably won't have to learn
other libraries like react
moving ahead let's look at the community
support
reacts framework is one of the most
popular JavaScript Frameworks worldwide
it has larger community support and you
may face a lack of documentation at
times the community support makes up for
the lack in documentation
when it comes to angular even though
angular was released before its adoption
is lesser when compared to react
comparatively it has a smaller Community
Support documentation is on point and
definitely better in the case of angular
also the community support has improved
over the few years
moving on let's look at adoption and
application
react was released in May 2013. react is
more popularly adopted by developers due
to its simplicity
it is actively used by companies like
Facebook Twitter Netflix Airbnb and many
others
now here New York Times is one of the
many popular websites built using react
every new section acts as a separate
component so if any one of the component
updates the entire web page doesn't have
to reload making the web app feel much
faster and smoother
this is just to give you a brief example
when it comes to angular it was released
in October 2010 even though it is
improved now developers used to ignore
angular due to its complexity at the
time of its release angular is used by
Google Apple Nike McDonald's and other
companies
now Gmail is one of the many popular
websites built using angular only the
initial loading takes time but after
that everything is so smooth because it
is pre-loaded onto the web browser
similarity of reactant angular in The
Last 5 Years
we can clearly make out that react's
popularity is increasing over time while
angular's popularity is more of a
straight line
moving on to job Trends a react
developer's average salary in the United
States is around 91 000 US dollars per
annum in India the average salary of a
reactive lapper is around 7.35 lakhs per
annum
when it comes to angular an average
salary open angular developer in the US
is around 73 000 US dollars when it
comes to India the average salary is
around 4.88 lakhs per annum
so in conclusion angular is a
full-fledged mobile and web development
framework
react is a library only for UI
development which can be turned into a
full-fledged solution with the help of
additional libraries
react seems simpler at First Sight and
it takes lesser time to start working on
a react project however that Simplicity
as the main advantage of react is
neutralized because you have to learn to
work with additional Frameworks and
tools
angular itself is more complex and takes
quite some time to master yet it is a
powerful tool that offers a holistic web
development experience and once you
learn how to work with it you reap the
fruits
now there is no better framework both
are updated continuously to keep up with
the competitor for instance while react
was believed to win because of its
virtual Dom angular equal Discord by
implementing change detection in the end
angular versus react is all a matter of
personal preference a matter of skills
and habits as a beginner in programming
you would probably benefit more from
starting with react
as an experienced developer you just
keep working with what you know better
we'll talk about the differences between
react.js and nexjs as many people think
that react and next JS works the same
we'll compare react and next.js and how
exactly they work but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will get all the updates from Simply
learn before we jump to the video do you
know according to Glassdoor the average
salary of a full stack developer in US
is 70 000 US dollar per annum and it can
go up to 125 dollar per annum in fact by
2024 there will be 27 increase in the
jobs for developers according to the US
Bureau of Labor and statistics so now is
the best time to start picking up your
knowledge needed to get started in this
career
if you want to become a software
developer consider the course on full
stack developer mean stack by
simplylearn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description box for more details so now
I would like to ask you guys one
question
so is react a framework or a library
pause this video and comment in the
comment section below with the correct
answer so first we'll start with what
react.js and nexjss after that we'll see
the differences between react and
next.js we will cover the differences
between in terms of performance
development cost community and many more
moving ahead we'll talk about the
features of react and next.js and then
we will see where next and react.js are
used so without further Ado let's begin
so what is react.js
react is a JavaScript library that
builds fast interactive mobile and web
applications it's an open source
reusable component based front-end
library of JavaScript
react is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript it provides a reboost
unopenated way to build modern
application interface so the component
that user View and interact with on
screen are referred to as a user
interface react is a library that offers
helpful UI building compatibilities
still it is up to the developers to use
those functions in their application on
the other hand it takes work to create a
whole react application from scratch for
typical application requirements
developers spend time to configuring
tools and developing new Solutions after
much anticipation developer created a
framework of react the next Js let's see
what next.js is
so next JS is an open source web
framework created by OSL nextges enables
react-based web applications with
server-side rendering and generating
static websites in addition next.js
offers additional structures features
and optimization for your application
next just take care of the tooling and
setting required for react.js
now let's see the differences between
react.js and nexjs
if you use nexjs and react for your
development project you will find many
perks and drawbacks of using those react
and JavaScript projects however this
critical front-end development tools
offers a seamless and engaging web
development experience however they have
different learning curves although they
both are easy to learn now let's see the
performance on react and xjs
now performances where next.js and
react.js diverge most the server side
rendering and static generation of next
JS applications makes them incredibly
quick they work because of numerous
performance enhancing features such as
image optimization because of this using
next.js for your project will improve
the efficiency of the development by
engaging automatic server rendering and
code splitting additionally SSR is
crucial for improved performance however
a few things rule out in this decision
of react although it allows client-side
rendering this is insufficient for
creating high performance application
now we'll see the difference between the
documentation of react and xjs moving
ahead excellent documentation may make
it simple for you to utilize the tools
for any software project identify the
best library to employ and more both
react and next days have excellent
documentation options the learn by doing
documentation in next year is guide you
through component constructions and
routing a similar setup exists for react
also with multiple tutorials outlining
the fundamentals now let's move on to
the server-side rendering server-side
rendering SSR a unique functionality
provided by next.js it gathers data and
fulfills each request when you have to
offer a distinct presentation to various
customers server side rendering is not
supported by default in react although
it can be enabled with the server and
configuration of your choice SSR can be
integrated but it requires more effort
also it's possible that developers won't
support this in future versions now
let's move on to the developer Community
we'll talk about the community that
developer has in react and next.js so
you should be aware that any framework
or Library you choose will have a
developer community that may offer you
proper answers or of you any issues you
run into in the Cutthroat businesses
react has a fantastic developer
community that is active in Sharing
solution via blogs tutorials videos and
other platforms we too have so many
resources on react you can check out our
react full course on the simply land
page moving ahead you will find so many
react talks and live users on stack
Overflow also on the other hand next.js
has traditional exercises compared to
other options but it has more GitHub
interactions
developer in the open source Community
are accessible and engaged in next
year's Community wise I would say
excellent developer experience is
offered by both next.js and react.js now
let's move on to the configuration
another difference between react and
next.js you should consider is
configuration react could offer better
support for configuration unless you
disconnect from the standard create
react app you won't be able to change
the setups hence you will need to use
what's already set up and configured in
cras read Scripts
on the other hand everything is
configured with next.js the next JS
templates allow you to configure files
such as Bible and test.config now let's
move on to the maintenance
both nexjs and react.js have somewhat
opinionated cras in this circumstance
they are well maintained and release
updates frequently all you have to do is
now is to keep up with the new updates
so it's an amazing features on both
react and next.js let's see the
development cost of react nxjs next JS
and react do not make into the top
paying Innovation list furthermore they
both are open source as a result
building an application based on these
technologies will be relatively
inexpensive now let's see the features
of react and nexjs
as we know next JS uses react to develop
single page application
here are the features you can leverage
to create ready to go Application by
using next.js so some of them are server
side rendering static export
pre-rendering automatic build size
optimization
while talking about react it offers a
routing and State Management patterns
with libraries like Redux
react can be used to customize any
project
now let's see where react.js is used
react is used in social media platforms
like Facebook Instagram pin interest
Twitter and economy platforms like
Airbnb lift user
I repeat Uber
media platforms like Yahoo online video
streaming platforms like Netflix
SAS tools like send grid and zapper
Envision app now we'll see where next.js
is used
is used to develop e-commerce website
marketing websites and landing page
because it's a static site generator
well let's go ahead with the next area
that is called working with react juice
interview questions
now as we know it react.js is as
important as like in other
tools which you've already has seen so
what is the jsx here jsx called
JavaScript syntax extension
okay so this syntax extension to the
JavaScript in react.js is in the way
how you express
to bind JS and HTML together to result a
js6
content so by using j6 you can write a
structure in the same file that contains
the JavaScript code that is something
more Innovative way because of that
react.js is creating a more buzz in a
market
so j6 actually helps making code more
easier to understand and debug can avoid
lot of boilerplate code okay inside the
Dom structure
now the next thing is what is the
virtual Dom see the virtual Dom is
representing a Dom in a memory
okay that is called virtual Dom so
manipulating the real term is much more
slower and costly Affair okay because
you need to repaint the Dom over and
over the period of time when the user
changes few things so
when the state change virtual Dom
changes and only the objects which are
in real Dom okay
update instead of updating the entire
object so that makes your page to be
load far more faster
okay so in Virtual Dom what happens this
is the real Dom this is a virtual Dom so
the orange color portions which you're
seeing that is basically the changes
which has been made okay these are
called Changed object okay so virtual
Dom is basically compare it's to the
previous state and understand which area
it needs to send for the updates and
avoid the other areas
okay that's what this virtual Dom really
works
so what are react extension react
extensions are many like you talk about
like in flux it is a third party tool
which is responsible to attach
the State Management feature you talk
about react native which is responsible
to develop the hybrid mobile
applications
in JavaScript so these are two very
popular and there are many more which
are available Okay so
like you talk about
architectural support you talk about
server side rendering okay so Redux and
there are lot many other tools are also
available so what is an event in react
and how you're going to create that so
react is basically offering the ideas of
handing the event very fairly easy so
let me talk about clicking anything you
talk about taking your mouse somewhere
so these kind of options generate an
event so for that we typically say alert
and you click on this render you click
on this button in a curly braces you
call the function to trigger to event
now what are the components in react
so friends react components are nothing
but a call View
okay like a complex view can be divided
into the smaller portions
a complex UI can be distributed further
to create more better and reusable views
clear so it splits the user interface
into the independent pieces of code
which can be developed and joins
later on okay so that's how you define
the component in and react so in angular
and react in both areas the word
component is very much used so the
component meaning is very simple you
talk about a view
so what is the state in a react so state
is react is nothing but is the one which
identify what was and what is now okay
if it stores the value for the specific
period of time which changes and react
is basically detecting those
so it is changing because of some
actions either taken by the users or by
the applications okay so keep tracking
about all those States what it was there
like in I'm talking about an
incrementing an encounter so that is
also the state a variable there okay so
the state object is always initialized
in the Constructor so it can contain the
multiple properties so this dot set
state is used to change the value of the
state object and set state is
responsible
to
perform the shallow merge between the
new state and the previous state
now the state holds the data that a
component renders to the web page
certainly because every time the state
changes so it needs to be stored
somewhere so this is how the state is
accessed as you can see this example
here
in the Constructor we are defining the
super props and the states has been
initialized and you're rendering the
states there are three different steps
are involved initialize the state render
the state and update the states
what is the higher order component and
pure component react higher components
are the component which are typically a
function okay that takes a component and
return a new component to you by
manipulating few things they're
basically designed for the reusing
okay so the higher the components are
typically a function that takes a
component and return a new component
okay so to in order to perform some
reusability
or pure components are the components
okay is a variation of react component
that doesn't
that does a shallow comparison of props
and State
okay shell comparison basically checks
what the equality
are we clear now so that's what the main
job
going ahead what do we Implement and how
do you implement react routing so to
implement a react routing react routing
also comes with inbuild
react modules and that particular module
to import it so
here we Define the react modules by
offering the route path where you have a
call left hand side is the name and the
right hand side is a component which you
would like to deliver it now so this
brings us to the end of this full course
on react.js for 2023 we hope you had a
lot to learn and if you have any
suggestions or doubt please write them
down in the comment section below thank
you so much for tuning in today and
happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here